you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice kristy
wright ramsey personality and
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones as we talk about your life
and your money
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five chris christie is author of
the number one best-selling book
business boutique a woman's guide for
making money
doing what she loves and also the newly
best
newly minted best-selling devotional
called living true 40 days to get back
to you
so we'll talk to you guys about whatever
you want to talk about in your life
christy and i are here to help you
certainly money is what a lot of people
call about but we'll help you wherever
you are
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
christina is in tempe arizona to start
this hour off hi christina how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
hi so um i'm 21 years old
um pregnant five months pregnant and i'm
currently in a horrible auto loan
i owe eighteen thousand dollars um
four thousand dollars underwater with a
26
interest rate you got messed over didn't
you
yes you were like desperate for a car
and closed your eyes and signed whatever
they put in front of you
uh yep i don't think
so i guess you learned your lesson on
that go around huh
oh i did sorry what a mess what do you
make a year
um about 25 000
okay man how in the world they qualify
you for an
dollar twenty six percent loan and
expected you to pay it somebody's an
idiot
uh there are shysters and they're idiots
okay
um yeah
the car's got to go obviously uh
i i wow and you said you're five months
pregnant
i am yes
okay i uh you're gonna have to come up
with the four thousand dollars to get
rid of the car
and that's probably going to be a loan
from your credit union
is your could your family help you with
that
they can yeah i just don't want to
depend on them right now
okay i don't want you to depend on them
either but i want you out of this car
it's got to go now if we get rid of the
car what are you going to drive
um i was thinking about refinancing my
car
um paying the four thousand dollars up
front and maybe still keep the car
and maybe if i'm lucky i am able to like
lower my payments and
no a lower interest rate no car you
can't afford
okay it's ridiculous i mean you make 25
000
a year you you don't drive around in a
car that's 18 000 bucks
right it just doesn't there's no way
this makes sense it's a bad deal
so the car needs to go bye-bye and then
you're gonna have a four thousand dollar
loan and no car
so we've got to get you a thousand bucks
or something 1500 bucks to get you a
hooptie to ride around in
okay any way that is do you have any
access to any kind of a work
i hate to put the whip on your back with
you five months
pregnant but um but you're in a mess and
i'd love for you to pick up some more
income to be able to address all this
yeah um i'm working 40 hours at a dental
office right now
okay about fourteen dollars yeah do you
have any access to
extra work that you can do five months
pregnant
i don't i was thinking maybe like uber
or something like that may help
yeah you won't be able to do that if you
get rid of this car and get a 1500 car
uber won't qualify you with an old car
like that um but you got to get rid of
this car
so um so where's the dad
um that's working
that's working um he's going to school
for emt right now
okay did i miss somehow i got the
impression you weren't married
oh no i'm not made oh okay all right
so are y'all living together yes you're
living together
okay so he's going to emt school and he
makes what
um well right now he's just working at a
grocery store but he's going to emt
school um we're just kind of living off
just minimum wage jobs right now
okay
how old is he he's 23.
okay christie
yeah i mean i think it's one of those
things where you turn
every dial that you can so what that
looks like for you christina if you can
start a side gig if you can pick up a
few extra hours doing administrative
something that's not gonna be really
hard on you five months pregnant to
create a little bit of extra income
on your boyfriend for him to take a
second job
for him to take a third job for him to
help turn the dials
in the income as well but this has to be
a team effort not just because
the car is a situation that's a strain
on you but because you both have a baby
on the way
and so there's this fire under you to
get yourself financially stable
have a stable vehicle to be able to
drive your baby home from the hospital
in so there's a a more of an urgency
than there would be otherwise if you
were in this situation with the car and
we're not
he does your boyfriend have debt i don't
know he has zero debt
that's good news okay all right i'm
gonna tell you what
i'm really thinking are you okay with
that yeah
okay because i i care about you and i
want you to win
i'm thinking about a 31 year old
christina
with a 10 year old child okay
and i want her to be in a really really
good place
and i think the best way for that to
happen is
for you guys to quit playing house and
be grown-ups and get married
you have a baby you're playing house and
it's time for
young man to uh pull up his boots and go
get six
freaking jobs and take care of his
family
and get rid of your stupid car and take
care of his pregnant wife
and he you all need to be married by
friday
and you guys need to get on with your
life and he needs to roll up his sleeves
man up now and and take the take the bit
in his mouth and get this
get this family taken care of because
five minutes ago i had a
pregnant fi a five-month pregnant woman
on the phone who got
messed over royally on a car stuck in it
but now i've later in the conversation i
got this young man standing here
and it's time for him to be that i got a
question for you what about emt school
is now the time for emt school with
everything they got going on or does he
pause the mt school they have to
you know that's what stuck out to me is
his primary goal is not his
self-actualization it's feeding his wife
and his baby well that's what stuck out
to me i was like this
it's not it's not never on emt school
but maybe this isn't the time for emt
school when you've got these more urgent
things
like a baby in a car well or maybe
you're just not home much because you're
in emt
school and you're still working 40
freaking hours right yeah and i'm okay
with that too yeah i've done that kind
of stuff when i was your age christina
lots of people have done that kind of
stuff when i was your age but you're
kind of
you feel like a single mom over here
yeah and yet over
on the other side i've got this guy
standing here and it's just
weird i'm just going to say it out loud
and so i'm going to be papa dave here
and love you and say if you were my kid
i i that that would have been my advice
to you the best way you can have an
awesome 31 year old version of you
is you guys you know let's do this in
the right order here it's a big deal
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out
at chministries.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in
we will talk so
a study done uh about a decade ago
says that
you need to only do three things to
avoid
living in poverty graduate from high
school
marry before having a child and have
that child after age
twenty only eight percent
of the people who do those three things
fall into poverty
79 percent who fail to do those three
things in that order
land in poverty those are statistics not
moral judgments
graduate from high school be married
before you have a baby and be over 20
before you have a baby pretty simple
basic life choices
and these studies go on from there that
show
you know uh a 2014 report
american enterprise institute did says
that adjusting for family size family
income is 73 percent
higher for married women
than it is for women who are not married
and living with someone
so as a woman's empowerment
issue there is a tremendous economic
lift statistically speaking
on average when a lady is married
and and so that last call that we take
from that super young girl
she was 20 years old or 21 years old
right
yeah um these decisions that you're
making at that age
especially for women uh
there's a there's a marriage there's
what's called a marriage list in
economics too that just shows that
by and large more wealthy people are
married than unmarried
and so there's some dynamic there and it
can just simply be that there's two
incomes
yeah you know the math could be the
cause of that we don't know the
causation of it the marriage is
necessarily the causation
but there there just seems to be
something that when people are doing
life together
uh under the heading of marriage that
that there's
you know multiple studies that show that
the probability of you not only avoiding
poverty but being more successful in
your life
yeah i think it's interesting how you
always highlight the economic benefit
to marriage because i think people don't
think of that now let's talk about this
this is interesting though because in
that
example with christina in that last call
i i don't know
if she wants to get married and just
isn't or if she didn't want to get
married either but there's an
interesting dynamic where typically and
you know i know you make some people mad
with this but typically
the man proposes and if you're talking
two women
who want to get married who are in a
relationship what would you say to
someone
that wants to get married but her
husband hasn't her boyfriend has not
proposed
because you don't want to be this needy
nag that's like well where's my ring
but at the same time you're like what
are we doing here what does that look
like
we're living together and having babies
together so it's kind of like
yeah this is like you know everything
the deal's already done
we just need to sign the deal right and
so this is not like
uh you're dating and you're uh trying to
press
there's not a baby on the way and you've
got independent lives right
financially and then you're needy that's
not you know
that's a whole different conversation
but um
but i would say a lot of people in
younger generations don't
equate those things they're and you get
the calls all the time they're perfectly
fine living together and having babies
and not being married
a lot of them do that and so i don't
think in in their mind they equate well
because we're doing this we must get
married or it means we should get
married or we're going to get married
they're just they're just kind of cool
with it you know i think some people
think that so what would you say to
someone
well let's let's continue reading so
many statistics because i think it does
address that you know i mean
only four percent of homes with a
married mother
and father are on food stamps at any
given time
21 of cohabitating and 28
of single mothers are on food stamps
so these are socioeconomic decisions
that you control and uh and the reason
is is that a house divided against
itself can stand
you know when you pull it when you're
pulling it two ends of something all you
do is break it down
yeah you're not pulling in the same
direction you have not you've not uh
committed for the long haul and so you
make short term decisions
yeah and it blows your money up and it
blows your career up
and it blows your parenting up and it
blows up everything
yeah and so you know
a goal in achieving the american dream
only 41 percent of cohabitating adults
and 44
of singles actually own their own home
where 78 of married people own their own
home
you're twice as likely to be a homeowner
married
see these are all wealth indicators and
so there's something going on here
of the joining of forces
versus shacking up yeah and so
you know and and people get all pissed
off because you know you're only right
to tell me i don't know i tell you
anything all you gotta do is change the
channel if you don't want me telling you
stuff because you're here
you're here because i'm gonna tell you
stuff that's that's why we call this the
dave ramsey show
if you want somebody else tell you stuff
get somebody else but
you know there is there is a problem
here that we've just ignored
because everybody's so afraid to address
this because it's a moral issue as well
a spiritual issue as well
it is but i want to clarify something i
want to i want i want you to explain
this to me
you're speaking to the issue of
cohabitating you're not speaking just to
the issue of singleness because the
issue of singleness you can't really
tolerate no
no no no i'm not i'm not you're exactly
okay i want to clarify that you know
and and you know having babies outside
of wedlock yeah
old-fashioned phrase okay but the
statistical evidence is it's disastrous
for your life
yeah yeah the numbers show it the
numbers show it
yeah and so you know there's something
to a shotgun wedding
you know or like you told christina by
friday you get her pregnant
daddy comes up with a shotgun you're
going to marry her i mean that's
old-school hillbilly stuff
right but there's something to that
because what it does is it sets you up
not in the moment yeah but it sets you
up for
a pattern of decisions going forward
that cause your next
10 years you're twice as likely to be a
homeowner
you are 10x less likely
to be on welfare yeah it's pretty that's
pretty
dramatic it is it is in the numbers show
it what's
what's interesting and i don't think we
have the data on this but i'm curious
because you get calls a lot of
times too dave and this may not be as
common
but you see a pattern where people are
married but
not working as a team they've got their
own bank accounts they've got their
hidden debts they've got all this stuff
and you're seeing an economic disaster
in their even even though they're
married because they're not working as a
team you're seeing the house crumble in
on itself
exactly because of the behavior but
what's so interesting is when you have
the
the commitment of marriage the structure
of marriage the
uh teamwork element you're forced to
work as a team it's much more conducive
to
those results you're talking about
because you have committed you're
putting things together and you're
working as a team
if you don't it's still going to be a
problem yeah
if you're not a team it's just
for your own daughter
you know you got to look at her and go
if he gets the warmth of your bed he
gets the 26
car loan yeah yeah i mean
these things go together yeah baby doll
yeah i mean why are you calling in the
dave ramsey so
show stressed out about your 26
interest and he's chased an emt school
i'm not against emt
school but i'm like it feels like he is
moving forward with his goals and you
are trying to clean up
problems in the past we need to
reconcile these two and then and then
make decisions as a team together as to
what's good for the team
the family unit and most of all for this
baby this one that's right there's such
an urgency because of that
and so um i i just i want you guys out
there to hear
uh this is not holier than thou
this is not talking down to someone that
there are some economic and statistical
details and indicators that are really
not
arguable uh that you're that are gonna
that you're that you're swimming
upstream against well you can disagree
with the morality you can disagree with
your stance or or
religious stance or moral stance and the
numbers still don't change the results
economically exactly there was no
indication i mean i didn't bring up
church attendance yeah but you know by
the way
that does in their enter into also a
wealth building thing but
a higher likelihood regular worship
attendance
whether you're christian jewish muslim
regular worship attendance is correlated
with
a higher probability of building wealth
because a character
is being built and you know it's a
pretty simple things when you think
about it
but you cannot leave these things
separate from i'm just going to ask a
math question
doesn't work sorry guys this is how it
is we love you guys we want you to win
this is the dave ramsey show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at 825-5225
you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money carla is with us in los angeles hi
carla how are you hi dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up thanks
for taking my call
going off your last segment actually i
am a single mom
and what i call all your gems in the
last three years have helped me pay off
eleven thousand two hundred dollars in
credit card debt
i'm proud of you way to go and my
student loans
wow there you go thank you for your gems
i'm proud of you well done completely
good i'm glad we i'm glad we were able
to help you
thank you so my question is now i'm kind
of scared i have some money saved up
i've got about a
50 50 2 000 saved up
and here in los angeles um they're
allowing adus which is
converting your garage into like a unit
that you can rent
and in my area um about a 500 square
foot garage is um
renting out for anywhere from 1200 to
1600
wow it will take about thirty thousand
dollars though to convert my garage and
so you know supposed to have its own
bathroom its own kitchen
and its own living space with you know
all the legalizations of the city
and i don't know if that's something i
wanna do
is that a smart investment for me is
that something that i can capitalize on
and i do also have one thing that's
haunting me from my past is a lease that
i got four years ago that lease is going
to be up in december
so that i know i'm gonna need about ten
thousand i'm gonna buy a car i'm gonna
have to use about ten
thousand dollars to just flat out buy a
car so i'll be
you know needing a lot of money there
and i only have about fifty two thousand
so i don't know if that's a smart move
for me to do what's your household
income
uh last in 2020 i made 141 thousand
dollars
good for you and the car lease is up
when
uh november december
okay well you're you're saving maniacs
so you could have some more money saved
by then right
yeah that's what i was thinking to save
more
yeah so i have a more cushion and i'm
just scared to deplete all of that so
here would be my goal you know and i
would lay the math out and see if you
can do it i want you to have an
emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses at
all times in this discussion
you currently do for sure so let's let's
set that number
i'll just make one up and let's call
that
25 000 okay i don't care if you make it
35 you can make it whatever
and that means you've got 27 000 left
over after that
okay okay and so you can start your
project
immediately if it's thirty thousand
dollars
and it does make mathematical sense to
do that because you're gonna increase
the value of your home and you're gonna
make all your money back
with additional rent within two years
right and i'm not planning to move
because i cannot afford a home
out here where i'm living currently
another home you know the prices are
just crazy high
yeah but i mean your home will go up in
value some
maybe not thirty thousand but maybe more
than thirty thousand i don't know what
it'll do to it by doing this
and you're gonna make thirty thousand
dollars more in two years
okay about eighteen thousand dollars a
month
eighteen thousand fifteen hundred a
month is uh eighteen thousand dollars a
year
okay okay so yeah we're going to do this
project i think it's a great project
and i think you started immediately and
you set 25 000 aside as your emergency
fund
and you cash flow you know you make sure
you that other 2000 or whatever you got
there
and then between now and november you've
just got to save up for your car and you
can do that
i can okay thank you so much i'm just
scared but i'm going to go for it
well you're you're not if you follow the
plan we just laid out you want
yeah you've got the savings it's just
the unknown it's the unknown it's the
risk it's the new that feels scary
you've got the money there and you've
got a plan to save more money carla so
if you look at the numbers the numbers
don't lie you're in a good position to
do this
and you feel competent to manage the
rental without any fears around that
right because i'm a single mom it does
worry me but i'm a nurse so my plan was
actually to rent out to travel nurses
to the la area because i see they're
always asking for oh do
you guys know anyone who's renting out
you know a room that has a small kitchen
a bathroom
because they get siphoned so i'm
planning to have so i think you
i think you can i think you pick someone
that goes in there based on
safety as well as yes as well as their
ability to pay
and if you're doing short term like that
you should be able to make i don't mean
i don't know
what location you're in carlo but
typically when you've got short-term
rentals like that it makes even more
than that yeah that's exactly right
so yeah i think that's a perfect idea
that you're not gonna rent to
um just anybody to to um
too intimidating whatever's right yeah
or parties or whatever yeah you yeah
and with word of mouth in your industry
you you know nurses you know
people are always asking word gets out
that you've got a cute place and you're
yes you're a great host oh my gosh like
i think once word spreads you'll have no
problem filling that
with good safe people doing exactly what
you want to do which is helping
traveling nurses i think that's awesome
you need to do some research and get a
proper lease
a copy of a lease that you can use and
you need to learn from some property
managers and some other people just talk
to people around there that do that
on how to qualify a tenant make sure
that they're going to pay so you don't
just take their word for it and make
sure they get a deposit
and and obviously it's someone that you
feel
the safety part of is going to be more
than adequate but
yeah the travel nurse idea is a
wonderful idea yeah and i would say
because it's your garage right there
like set some boundaries around i mean
it's right there
you know you're right there so just set
some boundaries around that even if it's
travel nurse you don't want party travel
nurses you only may show up your house
don't want to i mean
you don't want her throwing parties over
there all the time and you got little
kids
yeah i mean so it's not this ain't party
central so it's someone with a value
system that matches up
that you want to have next door almost
as if you would have them as a roommate
roommate yes because it kind of is i
mean they're right there yeah
and with your baby there too julianne is
with us in florence south carolina hi
julianne how are you
hey dave hey christy hey what's going on
i'm happy to talk with you
yes okay i am a
christian fiction author and first of
all dave i want to say
how much you have helped me with money
and christie you have given me such
confidence
in the moving forward with these novels
i just want to say thank you up front
that's awesome i i started out writing
some short stories i put my short
stories on facebook and my facebook
friends were like julianne
girl you've got to write a novel so uh
2019 i took the plunge i read the
christmas no one expected
uh 2020 i read the rancher next door and
a date on the nasa halep
so so far i am self-publishing on amazon
i'm selling on my
facebook business page i've got about
600 followers there
i've got them in a handful of stores and
i set up a vendors
as a vendor at festivals and so forth
i've got some awesome feedback from my
readers at this point
i'm super excited i plan to write
another two novels a year
on track for that uh dave i know i hear
you say a lot how you uh
started selling books out of the trunk
of your car and uh
crazy i know you do such a fabulous job
at helping women
in business and i just wondered if
either of you had any advice for me and
getting these novels off the ground just
a little bit more
well they're off the ground yeah here's
here's what
here's what's awesome and hard julian
about what you're doing as a you know
self-published author and all that
what's awesome about it
is you're doing everything yourself so
you can control it you can do whatever
you want to
the hard part is you're doing everything
yourself so you're not just wearing the
author hat
you're also wearing the marketer hat and
it sounds like you've been spending a
lot of time
wearing the author hat you've been
writing a lot and you've got plans to
write more which is awesome
but we've got to spend a little bit of
time at least
to wear the marketing hat and that
marketing hat looks like getting
these books in front of eyeballs because
it doesn't matter how awesome your books
are if no one knows about them they
can't buy them
and so i would say i would start
exploring other outlets i don't know if
you have a blog but even putting
excerpts of your books on
a blog on your social media on your not
just on your facebook page but can you
put samples where like every monday you
give a little bit of the story
and you're like what happened what
happened to the character what happened
next and you're waiting until next
monday to get the next piece of the
story
give them samples you've got to get your
writing out there
where people actually want to buy the
book they're if you watch me right now
julian i'm doing this i'm doing this
dave every
few days a week i go live on instagram
and i share an excerpt of my devotional
living true 40 days get back to you
it's to give people a sample to go hey
remember i've got this devotional hey
remember
hey you're not sure if it's for you let
me give you a sample you've got to get
it out there in the marketing julian if
people are going to buy it i love that
you're great at writing and you love
writing but you got to market also
people are going to buy it
and i like the initiative you've shown
you've scratched around
yes you pulled this thing out there you
got her done i mean you got the amazon
account set up you got the bookstore
account you've done
really well you just keep scratching and
clawing and hustling grind like you're
doing i think you're going to be just
fine
but yeah it's all about allocating some
marketing time
and dollars out of your budget
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
business boutique
and the best-selling devotional living
true
40 days to get back to you as my co-host
today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five paul is in atlanta hey paul welcome
to the dave ramsey show
dave thank you so much for taking my
call i just wanted to tell you this this
means a lot to me to be able to ask you
a couple questions well we're honored
how can we help
um dave back in the summer in august
i contracted coded and i wound up about
being in the hospital for almost three
months well i was on
life support for uh three weeks i was in
a coma for over a month
and i see you for almost a month after
that racked up over a million dollars in
hospital debt uh thankfully i had
insurance
so i wasn't responsible for paying all
that um
i've paid off my portion of it since
then um
also got married to the person that was
standing beside me through everything
and before i get started on my question
on the break you mentioned the
importance of a will
and i 100 agree but i also had another
document that saved my life it was an
advanced medical directive
yeah i filled out my wishes if i got to
the point where i could make any
decisions
uh because i refused going on the
ventilator uh four different times
and when i first went to hospital i told
them
who was appointed in my directive and
they actually contacted this person and
they authorized them to save my life
wow and then for that document i i
wouldn't be here now
and also the board i mean he's the most
powerful reason i'm here
um so after i'd have a hospital um i
decided to get married i've been engaged
for a while
and since then we bought a home um
just got married in december i bought
the home right before
we got married um i've sold my other
house
and i'm trying to decide what to do with
the money um
i have not been very smart with finances
in my lifetime i have no debt
uh fortunately my granddad always told
me to you know
pay for stuff as i went and not accrue a
lot of credit cards and things like that
but i've just been a typical person and
i've just blown my money like crazy
and like i said i just was introduced to
you after i got out of the hospital and
just a few weeks ago as a matter of fact
my friend wow
um so i'm selling this house for 200
thousand dollars
um i've got it sold i'm supposed to
close on in just a few days
and we've got some other rental property
i owe 400
000 on the mortgage on the house i'm in
now
i put about 25 000 down on it
when i first bought it okay so i'm
trying to decide what the smart thing to
do is because
after that about this fall and
everything it really changed my
perspective on life
sure what a deal
what a wild year the best of times and
the worst of times he gets married gets
a house and gets covered oh my gosh and
not in that order
wow so uh and a really bad bout with
kova to boot
but um yes sir so uh the 200 000
property that's selling is it paid for
yes so you're going to clear
approximately 200 000 plus minus some
expenses all right good
you said and you owe 400 on your house
and the rentals what do you owe on them
they're all paid for good good that's
awesome
okay it sounds like it sounds like you
have done well with money paul you said
you've made a lot of mistakes with money
you have no debt you've got some paid
for houses
i i don't know i hear i hear some good
things happening i don't know i think if
i'd have been introduced to you guys
20 years ago i'd be a millionaire that i
listened to people talk about on your
you know show cause i've listened to a
lot of podcasts since i was introduced
to you and
i wish i was there well you will be
you're you're on your way you're in
really good shape what's your household
income
um i do about 140 and she does right at
uh almost 50 000. okay a couple hundred
thousand there
very good very good all right so
basically we're gonna do what we always
do here and that's walk up the baby
steps you're debt-free except your home
do you have an emergency fund
i do how much is in it about 45
000. perfect do you have any investments
that are not retirement investments and
not these rental properties
yeah so you don't have any money in a
401k or anything like that
oh one so i thought you should apologize
yes i do
um i looked at it shortly before i went
in the hospital i just started
a job a few years ago that the first
time i've had a paid job i've been
just doing things on my own for a while
um i think i've got about
70 000 in that okay but you don't have
any
non-retirement investments at all right
no good except these houses excellent
okay well perfect well
that puts you at baby step four you
would start putting 15
of your household income away for
retirement that comes out of your budget
uh five is kids college are there any
kids involved that need to be sent to
college
i've already said my kids are i've
already
that's done okay then the only thing
left is to pay off your home
that's baby step six and so any money
you can find beyond putting 15 percent
of your income into retirement
uh and living uh is going to go into the
paying off your house and that includes
the 200 000 here
so i suspect you'll have a paid for home
and two paid for rental properties
uh you know with if you put 200 down
that leaves you 200 to go
making 200. uh three years four years
you'll have that house paid for
and that's what i would do is just walk
you right up those baby steps into the
into millionaire status and you're gonna
get really really close really really
fast
he's done well yeah it's impressive too
because it's so interesting to hear
all the things he's done right and it's
so easy to focus on oh well maybe i
didn't
do as well here it's like gosh you've
done a ton of things really really well
i mean that's that's impressive he's in
a great spot yeah the millionaire that's
that's around the corner for you so
that's awesome andy is in pittsburgh hi
andy welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave i am honored to talk to you i am
thrilled
um my main question well two things
number one i hate debt and number two
i hate divorce my main question
is about buying out my soon-to-be ex
um it is not where i want to be
at age 52 he decided
we were married for 20 years he decided
he didn't want to be married anymore
and he moved out the kids i have two
daughters
they were in one was in college one was
in high school at the time
they're both grown and graduated from
college now
he moved out four years ago pardon me
he moved out four years ago five years
ago
um are you have you been divorced that
long or you're not divorced yet
no we're not divorced yet he left
and then did nothing about it um
and i've been scared very like
emotionally
dependent on nothing like our marriage
is done no
desire to get back together i'm scared
to get divorced i don't believe in it
i hate it i hate the thought of it i
hate the word all of that
i agree with you but you've been
divorced for five years you just hadn't
admitted it yet
right and i think i'm finally accepting
it now yeah
so i kind of went forward and said
i need some closure and we talked about
it
my life has just been up and down i
worked for the airline for
20 years then lost my job there i went
back to school to be a teacher
again paid along the way what are you
doing now
right now i am working at a cyber school
as a secretary i haven't been able to
find a job as a teacher but i have a
teaching degree
so right now i'm making twenty five
thousand dollars
a year and then i take on six kids
to tutor to teach reading good what do
you what do you owe on this house
well um it's worth about two hundred ten
thousand
and we paid it off um i worked very very
hard to pay it off
um and then when he left he um took
thirty thousand dollars
out of it in a home equity and bought
himself a car in an apartment and all
this stuff
um so there's a 30 000 home equity loan
on it
right it's 25 000 now okay well that
obviously comes out of his share
right we we talked about it and this i
guess is my main question for you
um our house is worth about two hundred
and ten
thousand i don't wanna leave the home
i'm living here
both of my kids are are old and underway
all right
um so the deal we talked about
was that he would give me 100 000 of his
401k
and then i would take over the 25 000
home equity and also give him 50
dollars that sounds like a reasonable
deal
you're buying out his half for seventy
five thousand and you get half his 401k
um and this mess is cleaned up yeah so
you're gonna have a seventy five
thousand dollar mortgage is what you're
going to
go get so go to your credit union and
get a 75 000 mortgage on as short a term
as you can possibly stand
maybe five years maybe seven years maybe
10 years you won't need
a 15 year on that it's a small loan go
to your local credit union with no
closing costs and get that loan
and you should be able to get that and
then let's
work to get that paid off my goodness
i'm sorry
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i am dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money christy wright
ramsey personality is my co-host today
you jump in and we'll talk with you
about your life and your money she of
course talks with ladies all the time
in all categories of life and um was
originally known
for being the creator of business
boutique equipping women to
make money doing what they love her
latest bestsellers a devotional
40 days to get back to you
and uh it's called living true and so uh
uh check that out as well again i we did
a devotional we didn't know it's gonna
be best seller but it was took look at
that there you go
all right cj is with us in denver to
start off this hour hi cj how are you
hi i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i was just hoping to get your advice
on a car situation
um i bought a car eight months ago ten
months ago for cash
and the transmission is now going out
what'd you pay for i paid
4 200 cash
what is it my mom it's a 2011 kia rio
so i bought it with like 86 000 miles
because based on my research they're
known to go
into the hundreds of thousands of miles
so i figured it would be
cheap kept me from you know getting a
car alarm
and keep focusing on my baby step two so
what's the transmission doing
so it's not shifting i took it into the
dealership
and they told me it could go in a month
or it could go in five years
there's no telling when it's going to go
but it's
they confirmed it's the early symptoms
it just it doesn't
it doesn't know what gear to be in so it
shifts really hard from first into
second
stop and go traffic in november it will
kind of glitch and almost
it almost feels like it's stalling out
and then it catches
um so i'm going to drive it until it
goes goes
but i don't know if i saved to replace
the transmission
which will be two to three thousand
dollars or if i
save to replace the car entirely
all right let's do a couple things one
is we need opinions
and bids from people other than the
dealer the dealer is the most expensive
place to get a car fixed
okay so we need to find a quality
independent
mechanic in your area and go and have
them look
at it and say this is uh what we do
i mean tell me what we've got to do here
um
uh you sound like you're single the way
you're talking this through
yes i am okay do you have family in the
area
no are you in a good church
yes okay uh
not because you're not capable but
because sometimes
people in uh car repair places
will treat a lady differently than a man
was that was that diplomatic it's just
the truth
i i would put a guy have a guy from the
church or a guy from work just
come hang out with you and just stand
there while the guy's talking to you
you can do all the talking but i and
that doesn't always happen
that you you but you might get a
different answer and it's it's enough of
a chance that i'm gonna
add that step to this okay
okay and you're hearing me loud and
clear it's not because i think you're
not capable of getting to the bottom of
this
i just want you to get the real story
and not get
uh somebody think they can take you uh
you know
take you and so uh go get a couple of
different people to look at it and give
you a couple of different scenarios
there you can do there's three
possibilities brand new
on the transmission rebuilt which is
way less expensive than brand new or
worst case scenario and really might be
a possibility here is to
buy a transmission from a junkyard that
comes out of a wrecked kia
and they install it and that's probably
going to be
you know 25 to 30 percent of new price
now once you've gotten all those numbers
here's the formula that you use
you need one well you need one other
number you try to figure out from
somebody what you can sell that car for
like it is right now okay
so you paid 4 200 for it it's got a bad
transmission they're gonna drive it and
they're gonna go it's got a bad
transmission
so we will give you dot for it let's
call that two thousand dollars okay
okay if you can sell it as is for two
thousand dollars
and your repair is three thousand
dollars
that's five thousand dollars you're
gonna have in a thirty two hundred and a
forty two hundred dollar car we're not
doing that we're gonna sell it as is
take the take the two thousand dollars
and put some transmission
money with that you were gonna spend on
a transmission with it and buy another
car
okay you follow me but if the if the
sale as is is five hundred dollars
and the repair is
fifteen hundred dollars then that gets
you in there for two thousand dollars
and at the end of this story you've got
a four thousand dollar car
then you would do that repair
so repair plus as is value
should not be more than 4 200 if it is
sell the car as is
okay you get the formula yep i got it
but you got it
you in a car this cheap and this old you
want to put the cheapest
possible fix in it you do not want to
this is not a you do not want to spend
money on this fix you want the cheapest
transmission
even so like a kia that got in a car
wreck and totaled
that had 20 000 miles on it they pulled
the transmission out of it at the
junkyard
salvage yard whatever phrase you want to
use right and then they the local
mechanics
load sticks it in there for you um
and that now you got a 20 000 mile
transmission in your car use
transmission
but that's going to be way cheaper i
think
than rebuilt and i know way cheaper than
new the other step i would throw in
there cj
is and i'm sure you'll do this anyway
but just ask for referrals for those
mechanics to begin with even if you take
someone with you
ask for referrals because you're going
to have a much better chance of getting
someone trusted someone good
someone honest someone that's going to
tell you your options shoot you straight
and not try to take advantage of you if
you go from oh you've got a friend or
family member someone in your church
says hey you got to go to my guy down on
this road because he's awesome
he's honest i've gone to him for 20
years that's who i use for my car
someone that referred me and he's honest
and i stick with him if there's a guy at
the church that's an elder or you're
you know somebody at your workplace
that's a person of strong character
they and they know that and they say
what christie said then they don't need
to go with you they can just call their
guy
and say hey i'm sending cj down there
you take really good care of her she's
my little sister i'm gonna box your ears
if you don't
okay that's that's the kind of if you
can get that kind of referral
yeah then i'm fine with not taking
somebody with you but if you're going
stranger to stranger
then you know let's just work this from
every possible angle can't hurt
yeah work this from every possible angle
and i think you're very capable of
getting this done
i'll give you a prediction that you're
going to sell the car as is and you're
not going to fix it
but i want you to do the research to
make sure i'm right because i'm not
positive i'm right
and when you have all those numbers in
front of you you go okay i can sell the
car today for this
i can fix it for this this or this the
answer is going to be bing
right there in front of you which one to
do and we gave you the formula on how to
figure it out
you got this kiddo thank you for calling
this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit go to
blinds.com and take advantage of this
week's
special savings
[Music]
auto insurance companies love to play
the game where they see
just how high they can jack up your
rates for
before you leave because they want your
money
right well good news is not hard to beat
them at their own game
all you got to do is check on your
policy every year or two and make sure
you're getting the best price for your
coverage
that's all you got to do it's real easy
you can hire one of our endorsed
local providers go to elp for insurance
and the independent agents there will
shop among a gazillion different
companies and get the best possible
price
for you when you're buying insurance
always use an
independent company because they'll get
you the best deal
our guys on average on the car and
homeowners are saving 700
a year by having these guys shop for you
because they don't work for the
insurance company they work for you
it's real easy and i got to tell you you
can beat your state farm price
you can beat your nationwide price
because they got one product they got
one company that they can sell for and
so
uh of course they think it's the best
but it's not
and it's not the best price for sure so
text the word
auto to 33789 and you can get a trusted
elp
agent going in your area that's auto
text
auto two three three seven
eight nine this is the dave ramsey show
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today uh
justin is in philadelphia hi justin
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
well i was just going to get to my
question i i just want to thank you for
everything that you're putting out there
i found it about two years ago
uh we were about 97 000 in debt my wife
and i
um were our eight thousand dollars away
from cleaning that also probably around
the springtime
and it'll be way to go yeah one
yeah one of these days besides me and my
wife i'm a brother
we can't wait for that day to get here
cool
so what my pleasure to my question is um
i have a state pension and i can retire
in about 12 years and uh when i retire i
will be
it will be about i will get about 94 000
a year from that country wow my question
is how do i
calculate that into my uh
my net worth because i hope in a in a
few more years i can call you and chris
back
and tell you that i'm a millionaire i
love it i hope you are
that's the way to go well i mean there's
kind of two answers to it for purposes
of the technical answer is
it's not part of your net worth because
it's not an asset you don't own it
okay but the real world answer then
aside from the technical accounting
answer is
that you're obviously going to get 94
000 a year off of it so that's pretty
cool right
uh there's two possible ways if you just
kind of want to track it for your own
purposes
there's two possible ways you can look
at that
uh if do they give you any kind of a
cash value
or a roll out number if you were to roll
it over and you have a lump sum
if you leave or anything like that that
you can take
no no so you if you leave after 10 years
you would get
like 35 and then if you leave after 20
years you get 50
and then the max is 65
after 25 years okay
and that's uh that but that percentage
is not the line is that the lump sum
yes you so you you would get of your
income right your base
of your base salary yeah yeah okay all
right no
all right so that way doesn't work to
calculate it um other than that we would
be guessing
uh i can give you a method to kind of
guess at it
so you're going to get 94 000 in 10 more
years
if you did that at uh
7 percent uh
that that would that would probably mean
that you had a million
five in there okay if you had a million
five invested at seven percent it would
create ninety four thousand a year
okay roughly i'm i'm doing this in my
heads but that's pretty close all right
and so uh if you want to calculate what
it's worth today
you would ask yourself you'd have to put
into account an investment calculator
what um not a million five as a future
value
seven percent and ten years and ask what
absolute investment calculator what the
present value of that is
and that's gonna be
six hundred thousand dollars seven
hundred thousand dollars is about what
it's worth today
okay so that that's a guess uh but
that's that's the formula you would use
if you really want to back into it
because most of their calculations are
going to be done at either six or seven
percent so
if you're getting 94 you're getting
you're that's like
having a lump sum that's paying you 94
on seven percent
but that's not for ten more years so
it's got to grow to that and it's seven
percent it'll double about every 10
years
so well i i actually estimated up to to
retirement it's going to be about 94
it's not what it is now
if i retire now would be about no i'm
saying if you retire in 10 years it
would be 94.
correct yes yes and if you calculate
that on seven percent that means that
would
in order to create ninety four thousand
dollars income you at seven percent
you'd need a million five or so
okay now would would you do anything
extra
to for investment purposes obviously a
457b
yes i would do a couple of roth iras
that's what i would do
on you and your wife and be loading
those up as you go so you've got some
money that's not just
in the pension because you don't have
control over this pension
how good it does whether they keep it
solvent you know
it's a state well run um most of them
aren't well run
most of them aren't in trouble uh in
terms of losing your pension but but
they're really
most of most of them do a pretty crummy
job
of running the thing so uh you know all
of that to say i want some money in my
name that i'm controlling
in addition to this it's a wonderful
benefit if it all comes out the way it's
supposed to
and it probably will actually so
good stuff man thanks for calling in
that was fun watching you do that just
watching i was just saying i was like
okay
and his mind is just calculating these
percentages right here in real time
and i may be off i may be way off but i
thought get me a calculator
i think i was getting pretty close i
think i was getting close all right open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five jason's in spokane hi
jason how are you
hi dave and christy thanks for taking my
call sure how can we help
so my wife and i are on baby step seven
and
we have no debt including our house i've
got three rental properties that are
also paid
wow thank you we've got about
140 000 extra which is in my real estate
rental
business and i don't want to take on any
debt to buy another property but it's
it's just kind of sitting there and our
market here right now is
so tight that i'm not interested in
buying anything to flip
i want to buy something for a rental but
i don't want to take on debt to do it so
the 140 is just sitting stagnating i'm
not sure
really what to do with it and looking
for some advice to invest and maybe help
it grow or
what to do with it when you said you're
not interested in taking on another
rental property not ever or just not
right now because
it's just 140. no i want to keep
buying rentals but i want to pay cash
for it so i don't want to use the 140 as
a down payment
right right now what's a rental cost in
your area
uh i guess a decent one that's not a
fixer is going to be around
350 300 to 350. okay
all right so we got a little ways to go
to add to that 140 and it could be nice
if it was growing
during that time is all we're saying
right yeah yeah that's exactly how i do
it
and what i use is an s p 500
uh just a it's a growth stock mutual
fund
uh but it's very predictable it's going
to do exactly what the stock market does
you know what an s p 500 index fund is
i do okay no load so there's no
commission
and the money if this money sits in
there over a year
whatever gains there are will be taxed
at your
capital gains rate of 15 not ordinary
income
so will that be treated any differently
because it's that money is held in a
business account
and if can a business invest in a mutual
fund separately and
treated any differently yes well now
it's in a business account but it's an
llc isn't it
that's right yeah you can pass that out
to you personally
drop it into the account and you do put
it in your name
and then when you pull it back out of
that account to
fund the llc buying rentals you'll be
just fine and that'll keep you from
getting taxed you don't want to run the
llc on the capital gains i don't think
check your tax advisor but i don't think
so
i pull it out do it personally and then
when i and then i throw it back into an
llc
to fund the purchase is what i do hey
man thanks for the call well done yeah
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you
there plus they offer unbelievable
financial benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five well 2020 was crazy and your 2020
taxes may be a bit more complicated
because of that if you
drew unemployment at any point last year
keep in mind you have to pay taxes on it
this year
unemployment checks are taxable income
another big thing to keep in mind is
remote working if you left your
residence state to remote
work in another state you may have to
pay state taxes to
two states isn't always the case but you
gotta have somebody help you figure that
out so you don't get caught
sideways with these guys so you may want
to use
our new tax software if you have a
simple return
ramsey smart tax and uh it's
pretty stinking incredible 17 will help
you do your whole filing
brand new we just launched that this
week
and uh so if you got a simple return
that's what you do but if you've got
crazy stuff going on in a crazy year you
may want a pro
doing your taxes for you so either way
you can text
tax quiz to find out what's going on
with your tax situation
to 33789 take our tax quiz
that's tax quiz no spaces
to 33789
jean is with us in lexington kentucky hi
gene how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
i i have a question i am going to
receive
a nice inheritance approximately 175
000 uh i would like to keep this
in my name so that my children can be
the beneficiaries
i'd also like to hold it in case my
mother needs
uh more money for her care
in the next couple years and i'd like to
keep this
just private in that
my husband doesn't know a lot about this
uh what would you suggest i do
gene we need we gotta dig we gotta dig
into that why
why why why do we not want the husband
to know
just a precarious relationship there's
never been any respect for my family
and i really don't want him to
have any part of this should it happen
so um you know
that's the way it is been that way for a
long time so how long you've been
married
over 50 years
okay um
i don't think it is i don't think it is
healthy to hide things from spouses
i don't think it's healthy for you i
don't think it's healthy for him
um if you want to set it aside where
uh he doesn't have any access to it
uh that's very possible and um
you know you can but but you know not
telling him about it
is uh that's not good that's deceiving
and you don't want you don't be that
person
and i'm not going to participate in
helping you do that because i think
that's wrong
but um i know oh that i just knew that
um uh
you know i don't think he would let me
handle it
or you know have it he doesn't have a
choice
he might yeah this this language is
what's concerning gene i mean i know you
all have been married a long time and it
sounds like there's been
layers of problems for a long time but
the he won't let me with this money that
you're getting
for your family i i don't how old are
you
i'm over 70. okay
all right well what i would tell you to
do is to
contact an estate planning attorney and
talk about how you can put this into
a trust of some kind uh that
you are in control of and it's really
not
up to him he doesn't have a let you part
in this
except that he emotionally rules over
you it sounds like
um but you know what this is pointing
out is
that you don't have a precarious
relationship you have a horrible
relationship that's what this is
pointing out you don't
trust your husband and you don't feel
safe
with him yeah i mean that's that's not
trying to exaggerate it but you don't
feel safe to tell him something that is
happening in your life and for fear that
he's going to quote take over
right he's not going to let you take
care of your mom
from a account perspective he doesn't
really have
control it comes the check would come to
you
you open up an account uh you you set it
in a trust
um you can put in a simple bank account
if you want to but it's in your name he
has absolutely no access to it
now you're going to want to be sure you
have a will so that the money goes to
your children as you said and that he
doesn't get any control of it
that the tru and that's one of the
reasons to set it up as a trust then the
trust can transfer to your children
um and there's you know it's almost
impossible for him to break into that
with a will if you have a will and a
trust and the money's in trust
and it's you know you're the trustee
it's in control you're in control of it
or somebody's a trustee you're the
beneficiary whatever
however your state planner tells you to
set it up but you need to go see an
estate planning attorney
and you're gonna spend three to five
thousand dollars on documents
a will a trust and you're going to get
some legal advice
on how to do this uh in a way where it
all stays in your name where you're in
complete control of it
but he doesn't have any legal access to
this money unless you give it to him
and so uh but but honey you got other
stuff going on here
there's a lot of fish frying on this one
on this one discussion
and you know this is not really about
the 175
000 this is about the quality of your
life well this one's going to ask would
you recommend
counseling i mean they've been married
50 years like it's kind of like
not like it's like too far gone but it's
like are peop
do you think he would even be open to i
have no idea
i mean i it couldn't hurt right
because it's like to your point you i
mean you don't need to live your wife
this way gene you don't need to live in
fear whether it's about a
an inheritance conversation or anything
that you don't need to live like that
like you
there needs to be these issues i would
love to see you get help with them
get him to get help with them yeah
doesn't matter if you've been married if
you're
a church you ought to sit down with your
pastor and have this discussion yeah
with or without him yeah and and then
but as far as the
you know uh you shouldn't have from a
legal perspective
uh he has absolutely no access to the
money
unless you give it to him if you do what
i'm talking about
now if you just go open up a bank
account um
you know you can get into all kinds of
different issues then so i'm going to
say
let's put it in the trust and let's have
a let's have a a will
and then that'll dictate what happens to
the money
yeah gene i would i would yeah i i
if if there's something you didn't say
where you don't want to tell him because
you're scared to tell him
for more you need to get you need to
have some you know some help
some support do this if there's if
there's something where you're scared to
to tell them for other reasons you just
you need to have some extra support
through this
amen in case there's something you
didn't say yeah absolutely so yeah yeah
you need to sit down with your pastor
this week
and and let's get some stuff let's get
some people around you and figure out
what the flip's really going on here
ouch joel is with us in omaha nebraska
hi joel how are you
hey i'm good doing good thanks thanks
for having me dave and christy a
pleasure
sure how can we help hey i'm a
self-employed
carpenter contractor in a small rural
community
i started this business about four years
ago and
so far i haven't hired any employees and
just looking for some advice
or wisdom on making that jump
i'm sorry i would say that again he's
trying to decide whether to hire
employees oh
in his carpentry business yeah and
hiring the first one
yeah are you um are you maxed out what's
the demand like right now what's your
business like
oh it fluctuates with the seasons of
course
but uh physically i know i can't do that
by myself forever but on the other hand
i've got a small market
so i don't know yeah emotionally
hiring your first employee is the
hardest
and financially it's the hardest
and obviously whatever you're going to
pay this person you need to have some
money stash back to make sure you can
honor your word and that the paycheck is
clear and
on top of that you need to be looking at
it and say if i'm going to pay this
person
you know 30 000 a year i got to make
more than 30 000
a year extra because they're around and
that's called a return on investment on
your
a payroll and so that's the hardest one
to do is the first one the second one's
easier the third one's easier the fourth
one's easier
and so on because you're you know you
get
you get better at the whole process this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is
my co-host today open phone's a triple h
8255 two two
five so we took the call uh
about the gentleman's wanting to hire
his first team members but
i am still stuck with the 70 plus year
old lady in lexington
who is in obviously a very dysfunctional
marriage
yeah been married 50 years yeah like
this is not like this is a new thing
yeah and and i think um
so anytime i can find somebody that is
in a
a bad situation particularly
late in life what i want to learn from
that
if i'm in this audience listening to
this is how to not end up there
like i mean if you talk to somebody
who's in their 70s they have zero money
it's a bad situation right they're
living off social security social
insecurity right
starving to death because that's no
picnic
then i want to learn how not to be that
person so how do you not
end up there yeah where she is
yeah you know i think what's interesting
and you've talked about this before
in any area of life life choices that
type of thing i don't think it's this
um i don't think it's an overnight thing
i don't think it's one of those things
it's some tragedy or some
you flip a switch it's by degrees by
degrees
we make bad choices by degrees we settle
by degrees we compromise by degrees we
let someone have power over us by
degrees we let things go don't set
boundaries don't communicate
by degrees and you wake up one day i'm
just guessing here on this
call for example and you make a
statement that sounds totally normal to
you
i can't tell him because he won't let me
do that with my money
and that sounds normal to you because by
degrees over 50 years
there have become these grooves in your
relationship of what has been allowed
what has been
acceptable what has been permitted that
you are in this very unhealthy dynamic
very unhealthy roles
but i don't think it started that way i
don't think they were like that when
they walked in the aisle i wouldn't
imagine
you know but you know
some things you know your wealth your
health
your relationships your
leadership your business your career
there there is no such thing as status
quo nothing stays the same
it is growing or it's dying and
typically if it's growing it's a matter
of you've been intentional about it
if it's dying it's because you you know
your garden if your garden is full of
weeds it's because you let it go
no one said oh let's intentionally build
a garden full of weeds
right but you just let it go right you
didn't do anything
if you want a a beautiful rose garden
you know you've got to put the manure
down you got to you got to do the
trimmings you got
you got to do the cuttings you have to
uh
prune the dead wood away
and you have to weed and so a series of
constant
incremental intentional acts cause you
to grow
and become better and better and better
and better
in a given area of your life or
relationships
not doing that it just deteriorates so
as you said it didn't start out
in the place she is but
you know so what i want folks to take
from that call
is um we used to have a guy work here he
said sometimes people like that are an
anti-mentor
they're the opposite of a mentor this is
what not to do
okay so what not to do is to
35 years ago not have dealt with it
whatever it is right and um
you know it because you know uh you know
i'll just i'm just not gonna worry about
it well then your guard's gonna have
weeds
do you think there's something do you
think there's a generational thing i'm
sure there's a value thing
with this maybe it's personality style
whatever where it's this idea of like
i'm gonna sweep it under the rug
because that's the be the bigger person
i'm going to take the higher ground
it's the polite southern godly christian
thing to do i've told matt before we
have conversation like i don't sleep
anything in the rug my rug is clean you
can lift it up any time because i just
air things all like i'm very open
communicator but i think some people
think that that's
the open communication is almost
offensive where it's like well let's
just sleep it in the rug let it go
that type of thing but your rug builds
up if you just sweep things under the
rug for years and years and years you
get to the point
where you've got so much built up
resentment and such an unhealthy dynamic
because you didn't to your point
deal with things when they were
happening
and it becomes it it becomes very
unhealthy well
we talk about and you help teach this
too we're teaching in entree leadership
is
uh with a team member that's misbehaving
or that is not performing or whatever
if you you know in the name of being
nice
sweep it under the rug don't deal with
it eventually
it uh you know it's going to explode
because it's going to get bad enough
that that and you finally get so
frustrated
they don't even know you're frustrated
right did you just walk in mad and
firearm didn't you tell
didn't you tell a story one time that
you got fired you still don't know why
yeah
i did i'll probably deserve to dig into
that i probably deserved it you know
yeah but uh uh but i'll never know the
guy's dead now
it was a long time ago just out of
college you know but he just walked in
and cussed at me
and threw a box on my table and said get
your blankety blank
blank stuff and blankety out of here and
i'm like what i do
you don't even want to know just get out
of here and i'm just like my god
well i don't know i still don't know but
um
i know he was a jerk i know that part
but i i but that doesn't mean i wasn't
right that doesn't mean i didn't deserve
it but the point is you let things build
up and so we always use the saying
when you're dealing with team members or
in and it applies in these other
other parts of this discussion too to be
unclear is to be unkind
to not uh deal with whatever there is
there right and put it out there and go
this is this is what's going on
yeah and this is the way this is what i
would say to anybody listening right now
that they is something's coming to mind
whether it's in their marriage or
in their job or whatever and they're
going oh yeah i really you know i really
hate that i don't even want to deal with
it i don't face it
fast forward 30 years what's that going
to look like if you don't you know what
i mean
that it's not going to go away it's not
going to magically things don't
magically just get better
they get better with a lot of hard work
and intentionality it was kind of like
what you're talking about a minute ago
because
there's this gap between our intentions
that we have and the outcomes that we
get and what fills the gap is discipline
or not
you're either working on it and growing
like the garden example or it's dying
and so if you don't have that
intentional discipline
to act on your intentions not just oh i
know i should read a book oh i know i
should go to counseling oh i know i
should work
no one doesn't do anything it's not the
thought that counts it's what you do
that counts that leads to the outcomes
and if i intend to send my wife flowers
and i don't
i get no credit for that it's not
bragging about what you thought about
doing for her in a
y'all's anniversary it's what you
actually do
yeah that counts you know this is
reminding me because sharon palooza is
coming up her birthday is in
uh and our first date was in february
her birthday's in february and so
is valentine's day so february is pretty
much sharon palooza
i better get my act together i better
get i better get some stuff going right
now
it's not the thought that counts yeah
that's what you do it's the thought that
they cast
no it's not you know nobody cares what
you thought about
i intended to send you flowers you got
no credit for that no
i intended to dot dot dot you get no
credit for that you're not bragging
about what your kids thought about
getting on the report card no
it's what they actually get and so i
think there's a great message here
there's a great message this
intentionality you know i'll give you a
real a true story example so the
beginning of this year
dave matt and i sat down we worked on
all of our goals what are our priorities
for the year what do we want to focus on
what are the trips we want to take
you know who do we want to be how do we
want to just improve individually and
separate whatever
well one of the things i wrote down this
is me being real honest right now i just
want to be kinder you know i i want to
be just
just kinder in general i want to
practice kindness and so
not me
i'm gonna add that he's like really i'm
gonna add that to your list for you when
you're not looking
okay all right so i wrote this down so
true story i wrote this down and i'm
like yes this is my intention okay i
want to be kinder and here's the things
that's what we're going to focus on
next day i was getting so frustrated
about something
and i just felt like the anger rising it
was something at the house something
with the kids and i found myself just
like getting real frustrated and i felt
the lord stirring me
are you just going to think about being
kinder or are you going to actually take
this moment to practice
doing what you said you wanted to do are
you going to give up your right to be
right are you going to give up your
right to be angry
and instead of stomping downstairs and
having a big fit about whatever you
think you have the right to be meta
are you going to actually do something
about what you said you're going to do
and it was like this moment
of because in in theory everything
sounds good but in real life of having
to walk out some of the things having to
deal with those things that were
sweeping under the rug
act out kindness it's hard it's hard
but that's what produces the results
that's what produces the marriage that's
what produces the outcome
project the current trajectory
of that section of your life out 50
years and see where it's taking you
you may need some adjustments i think we
all might
that's my reminder from that that's the
reminder i got out of that
the anti-mentor this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five abigail is in orlando
starting off this hour
hi abigail how are you hey dave i'm
doing good thanks for taking my call
today
sure what's up so i have been
saving up during forbearance period
because i just graduated in may
and i have over 140 grand and loans
good lord are you a doctor or a lawyer
nope i am a first generation college
student who didn't realize what i was
getting into going to a private
university
down in west palm beach so now i'm aware
but
uh i got a computer science degree so
hoping that that'll at least
help me somewhat to be able absolutely
have you landed the uh the tech
job yet yes i've been working
since september and uh actually a
company down in palm beach gardens um so
i'm
working there i've been working here for
a while so it's been a good fit
what are you making uh 67 right now
good good and that's your first job out
of college that's nice good
so you got a good you got a good
information systems or technology degree
for four years computer science degree
and that sets you up to uh you know to
if if you will keep
reading studying and stay cutting edge
in the tech world your income's going to
double in the next three to five years
yeah and that's my point i'm working on
some certificates right now yes
um for security so that's yes yes
excellent
well it'll more than double if you go
into that side
yes the hottest one of the hottest
segments in all of technology right now
very well done that's a good choice
thank you and i have some
managerial experience from college too
so hoping that'll
help boost possibly management and cyber
security but today i was just crying
because
i've had some friends recently been uh
saying i should be saving for a down
payment uh her house in florida since
yeah your friends are wrong
you don't need taking financial advice
for broke people you have 140 000
in student loan debt that's a crisis you
got to get rid of that
yeah that's what i was thinking too but
i was my mom said you should call dave
ramsey so i was like okay mine is
well your mom your mom set you up
mom's mom's got some sense mom set you
up she knew what i was going to do to
you that's right
she's like friends are giving bad advice
let me send her to the guy
listen yeah you need some r r you need
some
roommates and rent not buying a house
you need roommates
and you need rent cheap rent while you
pay off this debt
that's the focus and if you get gazelle
intense like we talk about you put those
blinders on
and focus on you will knock it out you
will knock it out and then you can save
her house and do all those fun things
but right now this is that's a huge
thing to weigh you down
especially so early in life do you buy a
car yeah
um i it's completely paid off i did buy
a car but i
it's paid off completely so good what's
it worth
it is when i bought it it was 17 and
that was two years ago
it's a family so i'm hoping it'll last a
while
so r r christie's right so here's the
thing
if i woke up in your shoes you got
nothing but huge potential
and the main roadblock to you being
very very wealthy in the next 15 years
is these stupid student loans
and so you got to treat them like they
are the enemy and they must be
destroyed they are the evil empire
yeah and we get mad every morning when
we get up at student loans
and give sally mae her eviction notice
out of your life so let's play with some
numbers
okay you live on nothing
you take all the extra gigs you can get
in the technology field
and if you put 50 000 a year
you're on student loans you're done in
three years
now 50 out of 67 doesn't work but your
income is going to be going up
and in the meantime you're going to get
cheap rent and roommates
and you're going to take extra jobs
until the income does come up
but i predict three years from now
you're gonna be making a lot of money
if you'll keep on the security path and
keep doing this stuff and just work like
a maniac and put it all on this
because because you're what you're 23 or
22.
22. 22. so by the time you're 25 you're
debt free
yeah and you're making 100 110
yeah now you can save for a house kiddo
yeah yeah definitely thank you so much
you guys i appreciate it thank you yeah
well done
are you gonna do that oh yeah i already
actually have um
it's not an iq but i'm i'm gonna be
referring on the side
you just started are you going to go get
out of debt in three years like we
talked about
yes yes sir i am okay we're holding you
to it
i can't i can't wait to hear from you i
want to hear your debt free scream on
that on the show okay
i will thank you so much guys all right
god bless you open phones at triple
eight eight two i felt a little too easy
um
if she if here's the thing if she starts
doing some freelancer doing some stuff
on the side
you can make some good money in the
technology field with what she knows and
what she can do
she can she can get that extra income up
asap
and she's used to living on nothing
she's broke college yeah she'll keep
leaving like a couple
she can dig out of that ditch real fast
yeah you don't have to run up a 70 000
lifestyle just because you're making 70
000 at 22 years old don't listen to your
friends who say you need to buy a house
right now
friends friends the friends the friends
i love it if your broke friends are
giving you financial advice
whatever they said do do the exact
opposite oh my gosh open phones at
triple
eight eight two five five two two five
time to put 2020 behind us
if you're ready to own 2021
actually accomplish your goals with
money your career your life we've got
the plan last year
left people wounded and stressed out dr
john deloney comes along
writes our quick read redefining anxiety
how to get your life back
what anxiety is what it's not and how to
get your life back it's only ten dollars
this year many people want to spend some
time connecting or maybe reconnecting
with god
rest and reset christie writes new
women's devotional
a bestseller as well both of these are
best sellers
living true 40 days to get back to you
it'll help you do it
and to help you with your money goals
pick up rachel cruz's latest
best seller just been out about two
weeks know yourself know your money
and this book will help you tackle your
money mindset so you can make some
real progress and reach your goals
even faster daveramsey.com
backslash store and be sure and check
these out the total money makeover is on
sale there
know yourself know your money's there
redefining anxieties there
everyday millionaires are there living
true 40 days to get back to you the
devotional is there
these are all things that have just come
out in the last few months not counting
the total money makeover it's
always on the best seller list
perpetually but these things are all
bestsellers they're all things that will
help you get ahead
you got to put new stuff in your brain
if you want new results it's a pretty
simple formula
and i don't know which area of your life
it is you want to work on but we're
going to help you
we're here this is what we do
daveramsey.com check out the store
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more
the promo code is ramsey it's magic use
it
all right today's question comes from
vic in massachusetts
here's what we've got i'm currently in
my third year of college i have the
fortunate chance of receiving enough
scholarships to pay for
all four years therefore i have zero
debt and will graduate as an engineer
student
from working i've saved a little over
five thousand dollars i would like to
start a business
i've been looking at e-commerce such as
drop shipping using quality product and
not cheaply made product
how much money should i put into this
business for marketing and resource
do you have any suggestions you know i
get this question a lot dave and i think
you know sometimes people are asking
different things when they're asking the
question
the first thing i want to clarify is you
never want to take out loans
not even a business loan a business loan
has to be paid by someone
and that someone is you so we don't
recommend any type of debt not business
debt not any type of debt
but when it comes to a startup i just
always recommend that people start
small and grow slow so what's the
minimum amount that you can put into
this business to get it off the ground
where you begin to turn a profit
and the business can then fund itself
and grow at the speed of cash the reason
we like to recommend this is not just
from a financial
risk standpoint but you want to validate
your idea you want to prove your idea
you're also going to learn a lot in
those early stages those first three
six months year in business about what
your customer wants
and what you need to do better so i
would just say what is the minimum
amount you've got a little bit of
savings
i don't know what other life transitions
you're going through as you're about to
graduate
but vic i would say a small amount of
savings that you cash flow to get it off
the ground
prove the idea and let the business fund
itself from there and grow at the speed
of cash
dave what would you say anything that's
exactly what you do
and so a thousand maybe two thousand of
the five thousand max
and um i'll just tell you i i'm seeing a
in the verbiage that you're using i'm i
i'm sensing a warning
okay warning warning warning one of the
uh in our world where we teach people
about how to run a business and how to
grow a business
christie's world in my world you know
with business boutique and with entree
leadership
um there is a
there's a lot of people like you vic
that
have a desire to own a business and run
a business
and that's where it starts and where it
ends they really haven't said i want to
do a business doing x
they just say i would like to hold my
own business and what do they do
they google own your own business right
and what comes up is what
is a horrible thing that we see quite
often
and christie and i see people these are
we see bodies
littered on this salvage yard and it's
called business in a box
and it's this idea that if you pay
someone x number of dollars they're
going to show
you know if you buy our kit for 500.
we'll show you how to do drop shipping
on uh ebay and uh drop shipping
and set you up and it takes no cash and
you're going to get rich
and it's easy and just give us the 500
well what you just discovered is that
they have a business
you are the customer and uh they are
selling a
business in a box and there's no such
thing the closest thing to a business in
the box that actually is a real thing is
called a franchise
and you might consider that but that is
tens of thousands of dollars at a
minimum
uh into something and so do not
do drop shipping that some
goober on the internet told you is going
to make you rich and you pay him a fee
to learn how
because all you're going to pay him a
fee and you're never going to get
anything going on
now so this is one of those things
that's it's like um
the other one the other one that comes
up is if you want to work for yourself
uh medical court reporting always comes
up
and it's like you know
you don't pay somebody twenty five
thousand dollars to be a medical court
reporter it's just it's just right
it's just right so instead you need to
start searching and saying okay i'm an
engineer student what's that got to do
with drop shipping
uh nothing
so i don't mind you starting your own
business but i wanted to come out of
your soul
yes not out of a google search yeah what
do you what do you want to do what are
you excited about what are you good at i
tell people all the time start with what
you have your skills your strengths your
stuff
you're an engineer student what can you
use in some type of business that you're
passionate about that you actually care
about doing mechanical engineering maybe
you need to design something yeah here's
the thing
business is hard it's awesome but it's
hard so if you don't love it and you're
not excited about it it's gonna be
really hard to push through the hard
times
about something that you just came up in
a google search that you don't really
care about
another way to look at it is what
problems do you want to solve in the
world
some of the best businesses come out of
problems that you solve for yourself or
someone else or
something you see that needs to be
better and that's what's wrong that's
what's wrong with this
the only problem this solves is he makes
money
yeah he didn't say i want to help people
right yeah he didn't say i'm going to
provide a service i'm going to provide a
goodie
i'm going to provide an item i'm going
to provide something i'm going to do
drop shipping
i'm going to sell people crap but they
don't even need yeah
and i'm and i'm going to be the
middleman and and
you read this on the internet vic that's
the problem yeah that i can just smell
it man
i'm not 100 sure but i'm 98 sure
it's just a bunch of words it's not any
heart there's no heart
in this question yeah you know so you
need to feel that you do need to start a
business i'm okay with that but it needs
to come out of your guts and not out of
google
that's good somebody stitch that on a
pillow
[Laughter]
guts not google on a pillow
[Laughter]
well maybe not i like your alliteration
i like where you're going maybe not
maybe i like the alliteration i'm not
sure i wanna know
[Laughter]
sarah's in spokane hey sarah welcome to
the dave ramsey show
good afternoon thanks for taking my call
um the reason i'm calling is my husband
and i
need some help um my father-in-law is
trying to convince
my mom my mother-in-law to close out her
inherited ira
because he's convinced that the stock
market is going to crash
so i want to know if how can i convince
them to keep the money in the ira
or should i have them move it
it's hard it's hard to convince anyone
who is suffering from political paranoia
to do anything because he's bought off
he's bought off on the idea that joe
biden is the end of the world
right and um you know every president
that has been elected since i've been an
adult was going to bring about the end
of the world by the people that didn't
vote for him and none of them did
you know i i yeah i totally agree
i don't know i mean how you gonna get in
his head i don't know i mean
he he is he needs to turn off fox news
this is what he needs to do
and turn off cnn and quit looking on
these stupid but websites
because there's no historical data
anywhere
to indicate that a single party
no matter how crooked or incompetent a
president is
has the power to destroy america
there's no data i mean there's no
there's no time in history
no matter you you can find the worst
possible presidency
in history and you can argue about what
that is and the stock market did okay
yeah so he's wrong he's wrong
uh you know we can we can talk about
whether we agree
with the fact that he hates joe biden or
whether we agree with
you know he went down a trump rabbit
hole of some kind we could talk about
all that as a separate subject if you
want but that's not a point
the point is i regardless of whether i
agree with all the crap they're doing up
there
i've never agreed with all the crap any
of them have done up there but i keep
investing and i've always invested
because the
data says the historical data on the
stock market says
no matter what [ __ ] is in the white
house we
still seem to be able to make money in
the dadgum
stock market right
that's the only thing i can tell her
that there's something that's what i
keep
yeah i would just say that dad there is
no
nothing to indicate that your paranoia
is accurate
okay and you're gonna you're gonna lose
a lot of money
let me give you another example okay how
about this one covid
is gonna bring the economy to its knees
and it will never get up
you remember that one i do and the stock
market
dove way down
in march and april remember i do
you know what it made last year almost
16
rate of return from january to january
and that's in the middle of freaking
covet trying to destroy our lives
it made 16 last year so if you freaked
out if you had a covet freak out and
pulled all your money on the market
you missed 16 on your money
wow this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for joining us america christy
wright ramsey personality is my co-host
open phones at
825-5225
george is with us in atlanta georgia hi
george welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave a long time listener first
first-time caller
my situation is i'm recently retired i'm
working with an advisor
and my advisor is suggesting to me to
convert some of my 403b
funds to a backdoor roth ira and i
wanted to know the advantages and
disadvantages of
doing that uh just a little bit more
background i'm debt free
except for my home i do have a pension
and maybe about uh 700
k in um this 403 b and i'll be quieting
okay i know you can talk it's fine um
the uh um okay a back door roth
is not what we're talking about he's
just he's just saying convert some of
this to roll it to a roth
throw it to an ira and make it a roth a
back door roth is a new roth that would
be you
want to put in new money and you make
over 200 000
a year so you can't do a roth and what
you have to do is open an
after tax uh ira and then roll it to a
roth the same day i do that every year
that but that's only eight thousand
dollars here okay so
this is talking about moving the 700 000
or some of it
into a roth ira in some good mutual
funds i assume right
right that's correct how old are you
65 okay all right
well the math usually work because if
you move up
whatever you move in becomes taxable do
you have
other 100k i'm sorry let's say it's 100k
100 000.
then you have whatever your tax rate is
if it's a you know
25 tax rate then you'd have 25 000 in
taxes when you do that
do you have other money other than this
to pay those taxes with
i do and how much other money
um about 200k okay
all right well if you pay the taxes
by rolling it to a roth from this day
forward it grows
tax free now
in order for you to make money as a
result of this transaction because
you're
paying taxes early uh
you you'd have to pay them eventually
anyway when you take the money out but
because you're paying them
early in order for this to work you've
got to leave alone
whatever you put in this roth for
probably the rest of your life and just
take income off of it at most
so i mean 10 years it you know
five to ten years somewhere in there
you're going to be really glad
you have let it grow tax-free so i think
moving a portion of this that way and
then using the other portion to live out
of
don't touch the roth to live out of and
let it grow tax-free
is going to make a lot of sense i agree
with your advisor
okay okay okay that is the question now
do i have to wait the five-year period
no i'm just all i'm saying is is in
order for the fact that this is growing
tax-free
to offset the fact that you paid the
taxes early
for the numbers to work out for a
break-even point
is going to be five years that the five
years is just when the math lines cross
you could take the money out any day you
want it to
there's no limitation on it and the
beauty of it is there's no required
minimum
uh distribution no rmd on it when you're
70 and a half if it's in a roth
so that roth money can just sit there
and grow tax-free the rest of your life
and you may never touch it and that
would be a
wonderful thing from an estate planning
standpoint
okay so if you could ideally that's what
would happen
and the uh so let's just say we move 350
000. you said you had 750 in the in the
403b
yes so let's like move 350 into the roth
and then the 400
you're just going to live out of that
but that 350 go ahead and pay the taxes
on it move it into a roth and let that
grow tax free the rest of your life
okay if you're going to do it that way
then mathematically the advice he's
giving you is correct
okay okay
well that was my question and you
answered it and i appreciate that
and he can he can actually i can't do it
on the radio because it takes too long
to unpack it all
but he can actually show you the present
value of those
tax dollars today and show you what i'm
talking about
where it makes sense at what point it
will have made sense and if you cash it
out before that
then this advice would have lost you
money yeah
so if you cash this out i can tell you
if you cash it out in three years
if you use the roth ira money inside of
three years you're going this is
this is a bad move if you're going to
leave alone 10 years it's a good move
and somewhere between there is where the
lines are going to cross and make it a
good move
the math lines but it's not a it's not a
requirement it's not a regulation
you leave it alone i just want you to
leave alone enough that it was the right
decision
does that make sense yeah it does and so
so i would assume then if you
are younger and you're definitely going
to leave it alone you would always want
to roll it over as soon as you could and
you had the money to pay the taxes
you know when you're not 65 when you're
45 and you call in 100
yeah yeah because you're not going to
touch it for 20 years right
for sure right and it's always going to
make sense if you can pay the taxes
without using the money in the account
to pay the taxes right
so like he's got the tax money on the
side and the side account
that he got the cash over there to cover
the tax bill and that's really
that's key too because it has the
mathematical effect of having actually
invested that much more
right yeah in there it's what you've
done because you've converted it from a
taxable account to a zero taxes and so
it's as if you
put you know if he did 350 000
and his tax bill was
a hundred thousand dollars okay it's as
if he invested another hundred thousand
bucks is really
in into a retirement account it's what
it amounts to that's the way the math
will work out
sam is with us in nova scotia hi sam
welcome to the dave ramsey show
uh hi dave thank you so much for taking
my call i always turn to your show when
i need someone to tell me i'm screwing
up
[Laughter]
yeah that's our new tagline sorry that's
our spiritual gift song that's our new
tagline thanks
all right so i'm a 22 year old student
i'm
in my fourth year at university i funded
all my education in
scholarships and i have a scholarship to
from the final year
i have about twenty eight thousand
dollars in savings
and uh my question is about starting a
business
with a friend i wanna know if it's a
wise idea so
uh six months ago my friend and i had a
business idea to start a
delivery service we live in a small town
where or whenever you want to shop
online it takes at least like three or
four days
when you pay for premium shipping even
to shop online and
we want to have a service where we
connect local stores with
shoppers because it's so cold here so
shopping in person is always difficult
the we participated in a competition at
the university to
develop a business plan and we actually
won first place so they decided to give
us
a fifteen thousand dollar grant if we
decide to go ahead with the idea however
the business costs uh fifty five
thousand dollars
and uh my friend and i would have to
each pay twenty thousand
to go ahead with it and so that would be
most of everything i saved
but at the same time like uh whenever i
look at entrepreneurs
they're like when you're young
22 perfect case big risks and
i don't know i'm also getting married in
april so like a lot of things are
changing
and i don't know is it a wise idea to
invest such a
huge amount of money in a bid okay
christy you don't need 55 000
to start a delivery business that i can
see it's a delivery business
right like you're connecting with the
local stores i think you can do this
for close to the fifteen thousand dollar
grant and maybe a little bit of your
savings i would also caution you about
going into business with this friend i
you both can do your own thing but
you know it's always uh it makes me
nervous to get them tangled up in any
kind of partnership or something like
that but i think a delivery business is
conducive to a lower startup cost you
can get scrappy
get connections and relationships with
the local store start at a small scale i
don't think you need 55 grand as a 22
year old to start a delivery business i
completely agree
yeah basically what you did was you ran
a a business scenario for the contest
and you ran out your budget for this
fictional idea right
and then the idea became real right uh
and so
now it's fictional again right let's
just do it on a scrappy basis
right and that's not the case that kind
of money yeah what's that let's uh let's
cut this thing out
and not spend as much to get her going
and if you're going to set up a
partnership it's dangerous christie's
right
i would prefer that you one of you be
the boss and the other one be the
uh one of you be the owner and the other
one have some rights to the prophets but
not be the owner
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day second peter 1
21 for no prophecy was ever produced by
the will of man
but men spoke from god as they were
carried along
by the holy spirit margaret wheatley
said leadership is a series of behaviors
rather than a role for heroes
ooh very nice good stuff
nicholas is in sioux city iowa hi
nicholas welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks for having me i
appreciate it our we're our honor how
can christina help
um i have a few questions i'm trying to
figure out
what i should pay off first i have about
thirty five hundred dollars in credit
card debt
i have about eight thousand dollars
saved up in the bank
um i have twelve thousand dollars in
school loans
my current total living expenses right
now are
twelve hundred dollars um my car is paid
off but i'm
going to need one soon it's got about
200 000 miles on it
um so i'm trying to figure out what do i
do with the credit card loans
um and then with the vehicles do i
purchase something
super inexpensive for two thousand
dollars to get me pet
um for the next couple years or
what do you make i make 58 000 a year
good for you how old are you 28 years
old
good for you okay so what's your total
debt
thirty five hundred and twelve thousand
twelve thousand plus thirty five yeah
just under fifteen and then did you say
that you have savings
eight thousand okay that's about eight
thousand dollars in savings correct
great well this is the first time i've
kind of been in this position so
i've kind of just been saving and
really kind of scared to pay off these
certain things because the first time
i've actually been accumulating money
at this rate and making decent money at
this point
yeah it feels good doesn't it feels good
to have somebody
it feels it feels really good yes it
does
well you know here's here's the cool
thing when you get this debt all paid
off
you're gonna get to have that feeling
again but actually get to not have this
debt
weighing you down you're in a good
position you can knock this out super
fast i mean you can pay off that credit
card debt
keep it thousands for your emergency
fund starter emergency fund just like we
say with baby step one
baby step two list your debts smallest
to largest by
balance which means you can pay off your
credit card debt right now and then
you've got an extra four thousand
close to almost four thousand to put
towards that other debt and then you
start chipping away at that with your
you got a good income it's not going to
take you long i would say i don't know
what the status of your car is but i
wouldn't worry about the car right now
i'd get this debt knocked out
drive the car as long as you can and
then i want you to buy a better car and
do it by christmas
with cash when you're dead when you're
done yeah and you'll be able to i bet
your car will go till then you can get
this knocked out and make sure you don't
make it till christmas
yeah yeah okay okay let's do this
we teach you we teach a thing called the
baby steps which is the shortest
distance between
where you are and wealth okay
and we've taught it to millions and
millions of people baby step one is a
thousand dollars
saved you've already done that you've
got eight thousand saved
baby step two is you list all of your
debts smallest balance to largest
balance and attack them in that order
with any money you can find in your
budget and you're going to be on beans
and rice rice and beans
totally focused because we're going to
get this paid off really super fast and
we're gonna use any other money we have
available so we've got seven
thousand dollars above the one thousand
total of eight that we can throw at this
now your
student loans do you have more than one
loan that totals to 12 or is it just
one twelve thousand dollar loan it's
just one twelve thousand dollar loan
okay so what christie's prescribing is
this we're gonna set one thousand into a
savings account
we're going to use seven thousand
towards your debts so that's going to
pay off all the credit cards you get
them out cut them up and close
all the accounts as soon as you pay them
off never use them again
get a debit card and that's all you'll
need it'll do everything a credit card
will do except put you into debt
you're going to get on a budget with the
every dollar budget
we're going to put you in our program
called ramsey plus i'm going to pay for
it for a year for you
and you go through financial peace
university in ramsey plus you start
using the every dollar
budgeting app and it'll cause you to do
that now we've got 3 500
left over because we put 3 500 on credit
cards we had seven
we're going to put that towards the 12
you're following me so we're down to 8
500.
i think you're gonna pay that off and
with your income
you're gonna pay that off in three
months
okay so three months from now you're a
hundred percent debt free with a
thousand dollars in the account
the next thing you do is baby step three
and we're gonna raise your account
i want you to keep on with this
intensity and we're gonna just pile up
cash now
and now your goal is three to six months
of expenses
in savings for a rainy day fund only not
to be used for anything except
emergencies
okay and in your world we're gonna call
that twelve thousand dollars
that's three to six months of your
expenses i just made that up you can
change it if you want to
okay but the goal is how fast can we
have twelve thousand dollars and then
save up for a car and buy a car by
christmas with cash
and you'll be able to buy about a six or
an eight thousand dollar car with cash
you'll have twelve thousand dollars in
the bank and you'll have
zero debt and that's where you're gonna
be at this time next year
sounds like a great plan to me and
that's gonna feel really good
even better than that eight thousand
dollars sitting there it's gonna feel
really good to have that savings and no
debt hanging over your head
it's gonna feel really good it's gonna
be worth that hard work between now and
then yeah we'll show you how to do it
i'll put you on hold and kelly will pick
up and
we'll put you into ramsey plus and go do
the financial peace university stuff
get on the budget i mean this is your
this is boot camp for money baby i mean
we're going to show you exactly how to
do it
and you just game on don't let your foot
off the gas until you get there now once
you get there
you can start investing for retirement
and you're going to start building
wealth you can ease up a little bit but
get that emergency fund and get debt
free
these are big goals and you knock that
out it's going to change your whole
position
well done very well done madeline is in
orlando florida hi madeline how are you
hi i'm doing great how are you better
than i deserve what's up
so um first i want to say that my fiance
and i
have paid off recently thirty six
thousand dollars in debt right again
thank you so much for thank you um
so we have some tenants that he my
fiance at the house in texas
and the tenants are moving out and we
have six thousand dollars cash
and i'm wondering is that going to be
enough to sell the house right now
we were thinking of maybe just replacing
the floor and touch-up paint
it's a mobile home and it's in texas and
live in florida yeah what do you owe
we're not sure if that's going to be
enough
115 000. okay what's it going to sell
for after you spend 6 000 on it
we honestly don't know because i know
that you say mobile homes go down in
value yeah
so i and i've never even purchased a
house or sold a house so i have no idea
my guess is it's sitting on a piece of
ground though isn't it
yeah it's sitting on about half an acre
yeah and you own that right
yes okay all right so you need to get in
touch with a real estate agent
in that area go to daveramsey.com and
click on elp
for real estate have them go out and
look at it for you and they and
ask them to say what i got six thousand
dollars how can i spend that
the best to cause this thing to get sold
and what am i going to be able to sell
it for
okay and they can tell you they can walk
through there and go okay you need to do
this floor
you need to paint that you need to haul
this junk off you need to break out the
yard you know
they're going to tell you you know some
stuff to do to get it ready to sell
the most efficient use of your six
thousand dollars right
yes and i hope to god that they'll sell
for enough to at least pay the bill
yeah that's what we're praying for as
well yeah that's my hope i don't know if
that's the case i have no idea what that
lots worth under it or what this
trailer's worth
but you know get a get a an endorsed
local provider
to help you with this because you're
going to need a real estate agent to
list it and get it sold
and they can they can advise you on and
even help you get the repairs done
you know help you coordinate since
you're out of town and then get you know
you get those repairs done
spend the six thousand dollars
efficiently you may want to go over and
spend a couple weeks and do it yourself
i don't know
to get the best use let's make that six
thousand dollars go as far as we can
and get this stinking thing out of your
life because getting rid of a hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt is
a beautiful thing yeah yeah that would
free them up so much financially and
just the headache and the stress of
having that in a completely different
state
and having to worry about it but i love
the i love how our endorsed local
providers walk people through these
major life decisions and
major life transitions because it takes
so much of the fear and the overwhelm
out of it they're experts in what they
do and they can walk you through and
show you exactly what you need to do
exactly good show today christy thanks
for having me well done
james childs our producer kelly daniel
our associate producer and phone
screener
great job i'm dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
you